let's go to uh michelle in eugene oregon
michelle what's going on
hey there so thank you so much for your
time i appreciate it
you bet thanks for calling what's up
yeah i'm so happy to be here so
i'm 54 years old and have spent over the
last five years making
really bad decisions um i lost a job
where i was making almost a hundred
thousand dollars a year um
spent about two years looking for a job
unfortunately i
thought it was a good idea to use my
retirement to get me through
okay so now i'm looking at covid i lost
my job last year
finally got a new one but i am making
almost half of what i was previously so
so you're making about 50 000 right now
right yeah
yeah and um so that hurts
you know by the time i pay off all the
bills every month i
have a couple hundred in my pocket for
necessities
okay um i have about five thousand
dollars in savings
okay and i got forty two thousand
dollars in credit card debt
forty two thousand dollars in credit
card debt
i know i told you i made some mistakes
okay
um i have 60 000 in student loans
50 000 okay 60 60 okay
yeah and that i shouldn't have had
because when
i was working my employer paid for my
education
and my son was starting college at the
same time
so i didn't want him to be in debt and i
assumed that i was going to forever be
making this much money could afford
to take out the loans what other debt do
you have do you have you have any car
loans
no no just my home just your home okay
cool so right now yeah
so right now you're in a hundred and two
thousand dollars in consumer debt plus
another hundred plus thousand dollars on
your mortgage
right yeah okay and you're making fifty
thousand dollars a year
yeah okay we have a shovel problem
i do i have we have we have we have an
income problem
okay yeah um what you have to do right
now
michelle is to really really figure out
what can we do
um you know um
right now
i want to say go get go get another job
i want to say
figure out how right now how to get two
jobs to get your your
your income up uh but then i also want
to tell you hey
you need to check out our career expert
because we need to get your income back
up to a hundred thousand dollars so this
way you can attack
your credit card debt followed by your
student loans
um and and uh real quickly because we're
about to come to the end of the show
um are you supporting your son
financially in any way right now
yeah okay cool great so right now here's
your thing michelle what you need to be
focusing on
is number one in the meantime go ahead
and get you a
part-time job that you can do on the
side to get your income up
all of that money from your part-time
job you don't have time to be eating out
you don't have time to be taking your
son out nowhere nice
you need to be focusing right now on how
to get out of debt and paul's
all investing okay i want you to pause
your investing i know you're saying hey
i'm i'm 50 something years old i need to
invest no we need to invest into you
getting out of debt
that's right okay that's the main thing
so
that's that's my main thing well and
here's the other thing michelle you
started this call
talking about all the mistakes you made
yeah you spoke
throughout the call as you were rattling
off a rap sheet
why you're have a life sentence and
listen
you cannot continue to drag your
past around with you and expect to get
anywhere down the road very far
so as of today you've announced you if
you have uh
called in and confessed to america to
millions
you did stupid stuff congratulations
you're gonna have to get in line we
all have we've done stupid stuff in
relationships we've done stupid stuff
with our money we've done stupid stuff
at jobs
all of us have every listener on this
show has done stupid stuff
you're not by yourself on this michelle
you have to put that crap
down and then be about moving forward
yeah so i don't want you to talk about
your mistakes anymore i want you to
to revel in them and roll around and
collect them because that's called shame
move on with them put them down and go
be about solving this problem with
another
job and another job and make this thing
go
this is the ramsay show